actor Michael B Jordan is adding a new
title to his resume director with a
capital D thank you very much he's got a
new film Creed 3 that's coming out soon
Jordan also stars in the film jumping
back into the boxing ring as Adonis
Creed yes please he says it's one of the
hardest things he has ever done before
he was a Hollywood heavyweight and he's
certainly that Jordan's first love was
basketball and that's why he created the
annual Invesco QQQ Legacy classic a
basketball showcase featuring four
historically black colleges and
universities we met Jordan at the
Prudential Center his hometown of Newark
New Jersey
this movie has pushed me beyond my
personal limits you know um so just the
the challenge of uh doing everything
that goal whatever was and walk into
what is Michael B Jordan is walking down
A New Path as a director of Creed Three
why did you think that this was a movie
that you were ready to direct you know
last time we talked to you said I often
wonder could I you remember that saying
this yeah could I do this yeah back in
2018 Jordan told us he was inspired
watching longtime collaborator Ryan
coogler looking at this brother direct
I'm like wow can I do that you know I
never knew that I could do that somebody
my age that looks like me from similar
places similar family backgrounds I
never knew that that was an option for
me like that now he's answered the
question he can do that take us behind
your process okay because some of the
shot choices I'm curious about how you
decided what you were going to do
definitely because it's very distinct
thank you thank you now everything was
everything was very intentional
obviously wrote for spontaneity but I
shot listed and prepared so from the
shot design to the color palette I'm a
very visual person so like colors and
and just those warm vibrant feeling that
you get from color I wanted to bring
that into this film and I went into a
camera operator as well I love camera
operating so I got a chance to get
behind the camera physically on this one
as well which was a lot of fun but in
setting up cinematic shots I wanted
things to feel very cinematic and big
you know I wanted to shoot boxing like
we haven't seen them before so we used
IMAX cameras to make it more immersive
that's why you feel so in the world in
the ring with these Fighters you said
that you felt yourself growing in this
role too in this new chapter in your
life what do you mean by that growing in
the sense of shedding my old self it's
one of the themes in the movie as well
as like you know owning and deserving
and feeling like you deserve the
blessings that you have and for myself I
put myself in a position where you I had
to sink or swim you know I had to run
towards that my past my you know inner
demons my insecurities my fears and I
tried to put a mirror up to that you
know throughout this movie
and Jordan's Drive reaches beyond the
Silver Screen the Newark New Jersey
native is giving student athletes from
historically black colleges and
universities a very unique opportunity
with his annual basketball showcase he
wanted to bring attention to hbcus why
was that important to you because I was
trying to find a way to level the
playing field you know hbcus don't get
the attention nor the funds
um to have the same opportunities for um
to be seen to be recognized we caught up
with some of the players a few days
before their games they told us the
impact of playing on this stage give the
opportunity to play in front of all my
people on national television uh-huh Joe
uh for me it gives us a chance to uh
show that hbcus have a lot of talent it
is life-changing for me myself
personally and then the university our
basketball team and just my family as a
whole we had a little surprise for them
too and you know this wouldn't have
happened without Michael B Jordan what
does it mean to you that he's behind
this I think it was really cool and uh
growing up I was always Michael B Jordan
fan like I always watching yeah yeah I
always watch his movies
he weak man I saw us that boy
[Laughter]
that's what's up man growing up finished
you were saying growing up I always
admire you man like watching your movies
you know one of my favorite movies you
were in is Chronicles okay Steve
Montgomery that was a girl me and my
brothers we always like to watch your
movies love that man appreciate the love
man it's the second year doing this like
each year child you'll make it bigger
you know what I'm saying get more
sponsors trying to get the scouts down
here you know I'm saying get the look
build up things just out outside of
basketball too you know financial
literacy you got to take care of your
money and don't live for right now live
for live for later I love that your your
email back in the day was basketball is
life nothing else matters
four the number four at the end of it
yeah the number four okay that was my
jersey number that's my favorite number
at AOL back in the day building yeah
building them e-i-l-n-e-m you love
basketball yes you dreamed of being a
basketball player for sure in the NBA
definitely
um I want to go to Montclair State you
know what I'm saying I went out there
hooped a lot and then sadly I stopped
growing and I kept working but do you
ever wonder what might have been do you
ever wonder like
you know saying like you know AI you
know all those flares yeah
knowing that I've played and played with
people who went pro you know and and and
have been competitive in hearing people
that actually are that in the league
know I hope that's all that's that's
that's all that my ego needs I'm good
I'm good the people Magazine's sexiest
man alive Alum recently poke fun at
navigating relationships in the public
eye all right I guess I'll learn a new
language anyway estoy in Raya you know
you were hilarious on Saturday Night
Live and I think a lot of people because
you joked about being on Riot I don't
know if you were serious I was joking I
was winning he's on wire really
that's intense I could help you Michael
I know lots of nice people hey send them
my way it's okay but you've been through
a very high profile breakup and how do
you process and how do you deal with
something like that I mean I think for
me it's just uh I was lucky enough to
have a lot of work you know and and I'm
a firm believer is what's for you is for
you you know and and coming out of you
know that situation I don't know not to
give it you know any energy and kind of
move move from that is you know
um it was an experience for me to grow
you know and learn
Michael I'm in my light right now this
is my Jordan year I mean that you know
this this is this is my year there's so
much going on so many blessings so many
great things this is at a point in my
career where there's not a lot of people
telling me no and everything's wide open
and everything is wide open listen I
know lots of men and women who would go
hey Michael when he says yes send them
my way hey Michael over here you know
but I can say this he's got the director
bug really bad he really enjoyed he said
at times he was directing with his mouth
guard in he had to get the hang of that
for a second he managed that but he
really wanted to do this interview
because of those kids he wanted to bring
attention to Raymond Somerville Kyle
Johnson Isaiah Burke Louis jokum Joe
Bryant Jr We Salute You And We Salute
You Michael Creed 3 hits theaters
Nationwide on March 3rd we'll be right
back